[Music]
um
michael debakey is a true renaissance
man
his interests ranging broadly beyond
medicine
to literature music history philosophy
political policy social issues
and varied other areas he embodies the
best
but it in the science and politics and
advice and wisdom and friendship and all
that but
but it never steers very very far from
just being a good
treat or patients you know the
patient-doctor relationship is actually
extremely important in any kind of
healthcare system
american people are very knowledgeable
about medical care
and then they're knowledgeable about
getting good medical care
that's evident also you see the
increasing use
of medline by the public michael ellis
debakey was born to lebanese immigrant
parents in lake charles louisiana
september 7 1908. his father was a
pharmacist and businessman
his mother an accomplished seamstress
the family name was eventually
anglicized from the original spelling
young michael's keen intellect
manifested itself at a very early age
and as a reward for doing well in his
school work his parents would let him
read the encyclopedia britannica he had
completed the entire
set before entering high school
and his prowess wasn't confined to
academics in those early years he played
several musical instruments
played sports learned to sew and enjoyed
gardening
debakey graduated from the tulane
university school of medicine in new
orleans
in 1932 and within that same year
stamped himself as a medical prodigy
ford was at age 23 that he created the
roller pump
a device that provided continuous blood
flow during operations
this was before the time of blood banks
so dr debakey used the pump to transfuse
blood directly
from a donor to a patient that pump
would find a permanent place in the
history of medicine
when some 20 years later it became a
crucial part
of the heart lung machine that made
open-heart surgery a reality
yes in democratic america everybody is
doing his bid
there goes jimmy stewart on his way to
enlist
with the outbreak of world war ii dr
debakey volunteered
and while serving in the surgical
consultants division of the u.s surgeon
general's office
he saw a need for delivering better
surgical care to soldiers on the
battlefield
auxiliary surgery groups or asgs they'd
be called
small mobile units attached to larger
field and evacuation hospitals
the initial deployment of an asg came in
to support the fifth army in north
africa sicily and
italy and it proved that asgs could
maneuver with combat units and sustain
operations
within just a few miles of the front
lines
so in the allied invasion of normandy
asgs supported the first
third seventh and ninth armies
debakey's vision came of age during the
korean war
as the asgs were renamed mobile army
surgical hospitals
or mash and the post-evacuation
mortality of wounded soldiers
dropped from 8.5 in world war one
to four percent in world war ii and to
around two and a half percent
in the korean and vietnam wars after
world war ii debakey's tour was extended
a year
so he could help shore up the veterans
administration hospital system
surgeon general kirk called me in and
said i need you to stay on
would you stay on for another year
i asked the surgeon owner to let me call
a hundred surgeons whom i knew well
every single one agreed to stay on which
really touched me
we can think of no individual who has
made a commitment to veterans in the
care of veterans
more passionately or more effectively
than dr michael e debakey
in 1946 debakey proposed that the
millions of military medical records
generated during world war
ii could provide a starting point for
valuable studies
of the long-term effects of wartime
injuries and illnesses
he then drafted a blueprint for an
agency to coordinate
such research the medical follow-up
agency
since the agency's creation as dubiki
predicted hundreds of follow-up studies
on veterans
have produced a wealth of information
about the progress of countless medical
conditions
in 1958 the agency began compiling a
database of pairs of twins who had
served in the military
the resulting twin registry which now
lists nearly 16
000 pairs remains a tremendous resource
for research
in the 1996 keynote address to the
national academy of sciences
national research council dr debecky
examined the 50-year history of the
veterans medical follow-up agency
evolution and prospects this handwritten
first draft of that speech is
illustrative
of the fact that debkey always preferred
pen or pencil and paper
writing it out longhand rather than use
a typewriter word processor
or computer in fact colleagues say
he didn't even own a personal computer
until his wife gave him a laptop
in the final months of his life
when debakey returned to civilian life
he went back to the tulane school of
medicine
but in 1948 moved to baylor university
in houston
which at the time had a small rather
undistinguished medical school
early on dr debake's quest to develop a
world-class medical center in houston
met with opposition and he became
disenchanted planning to return to
tulane
the baylor board of trustees intervened
however and persuaded debakey to stay at
baylor
giving him kart blush to fix things
the fix was accelerated soon after when
the houston navy hospital was turned
over to the veterans administration
and debakey was asked to help staff and
run it
the va hospital became a teaching
facility of the baylor college of
medicine
and would later be renamed the michael
debakey veterans affairs
medical center debakey's surgical
excellence and innovation
soon made the medical world take notice
of baylor and
houston and help transform both
dr debakey became a professor of surgery
and chairman of the department of
surgery at the baylor college of
medicine
where he later served as president from
1969 to 1979
and chancellor from 1979 to 1996.
as the years passed he earned a
worldwide reputation as a medical
statesman
advising every u.s president from harry
truman to george w
bush as well as international heads of
state and royalty
when great britain's duke of windsor
traveled to houston for a date with
debakey's scalpel
he quipped i'm going to see the maestro
in the 1950s dr debakey partnered with
another brilliant heart surgeon
dr denton cooley they formed a
formidable team at the baylor college of
medicine and methodist hospital in
houston
but in 1960 cooley went his separate way
one of the reasons i separated from mike
was i felt that he was too
abusive of all of his residents and
medical students and so forth and i
didn't think i could
be permanently involved in that
environment i was never
let's say anything around or hitting
anybody or anything like that
there are times when i was pretty sharp
with my tongue
but mostly i was trying to
to uh show them how to eliminate errors
you know dr devaki has sometimes has a
reputation of being a little bit
hard to satisfy at least in the
operating room
no but he's incredibly good to patients
yes that's hard very he was very
very considerate and attentive to the
patients
and i remember when i was at um
at bellevue we would go we saw a friend
uh
my follow him we'll see patients and he
he was a little bit like the grandfather
of everybody there yeah
exactly very very nice and generous of
himself
debkey the tough taskmaster existed in
sharp contrast
with the dr debakey whose soothing
compassionate nurturing demeanor with
patients
became a hallmark of his career dr o h
fraser recalls his student days and
debakey's response
to fraser's being late for a surgery
that was scheduled for 7 am
he said well you know if you really
cared if you actually cared about the
patient you would have been here at six
you see if you were here at six then you
could have
seen the patient shed his anxieties
seen what the anesthesia could do to
help calm them
and you could have been with him and you
could have learned a lot but of course
you would have to care
to do that since you obviously don't
care you know
he just wouldn't let you off the hook
you know when you look at his schedule
what he needed to accomplish within a
24-hour period or the week period or
whatever i mean he didn't have
any real free time and so things that
would interfere
with that with his time schedule would
be very irritating to him and he would
want to minimize those and so
he did it by being a tough task master
and you know once he was on you
you made sure that didn't happen again
his schedule went on as
his program through the 1950s and 60s
debakey's accomplishments
laid a solid foundation for his soaring
reputation
in 1952 dr debakey successfully repaired
an aortic aneurysm a ballooning of an
artery by cutting out the damaged
segment in the abdomen
and replacing it with a graft from a
cadaver
in 1953 he performed the first
successful carotid endarterectomy
the removal of fatty plaque from the
neck arteries as a treatment for stroke
debacy can actually thank luck for one
of his major innovations
you see seeking to use synthetic instead
of cadaver grafts
he went to a department store to buy
some nylon but the store was
out of dylon so a clerk suggested a new
product
dacron dr debakey liked its field
bought a yard and then used his wife's
sewing machine to create his first
artificial arterial patches
and tubes dacron turned out to last for
decades as a surgical graft
while nylon by contrast broke down after
about a year
in 1964 dr deveki's team accomplished
the first successful
coronary artery bypass using a
transplanted leg vein
to reroute blood beyond the blocked
coronary arteries
and in 1966 he performed the first
successful implantation
of a ventricular assist device vad that
he had developed
a heart pump to effectively bypass the
left ventricle of the heart
the chamber that does the pumping it was
also in the mid-60s that debakey chaired
president johnson's commission
on heart disease cancer and stroke
in addition regional medical centers can
provide the most
advanced diagnosis and treatment for
heart disease
and cancer and stroke and other major
diseases
there were a number of things that came
out of it that were worthwhile for
example you take
the widespread steps of the coronary
intensive care units
that really came directly out of the rnp
program that's a good example
i would say that that the cancer
the cancer institute's program
largely uh was developed as a
consequence of this report
even though the regional medical program
failed the
cancer institute you know took off he
creates
systems concepts ideas
and he has the stick-to-itiveness
to see them through to reality one of
the important visions that debacy began
pursuing during the 1960s and 70s
was the total artificial heart in 1963
he convinced congress to allocate
funding
for an artificial heart program at nih
to spur the development of mechanical
heart replacements
within a few years he and other
researchers were testing their
experimental hearts
in animals and discovering myriad
problems that would have to be solved
before the devices could be used in
humans
in 1969 some nine years after dr cooley
dissolved the debacy partnership
the two were plunged into an infamous
feud when cooley without debacy's
knowledge or approval
commandeered an artificial heart
prototype that debakey had developed
and implanted it into a patient for 40
years debacy refused to talk to cooley
in the 1980s debakey happened to perform
a life-saving heart transplant
on an engineer who worked for nasa and
that chance encounter marked the start
of a collaboration
between the space agency and the surgeon
so working with nasa engineers debakey
helped develop
a space-age version of the ventricular
assist device
there are scores of surgical instruments
that he invented
and this latest ventricular assist
device is really a wonderful little
contraption this marvelous little pump
i mean he has a a pump which is not much
bigger than my thumb
that can pump six liters a minute it's
about the size of a double a battery
it's an actual flow pump so no valves
so it makes it very simple you see and
because of its size
it's easily implantable in the chest now
the pump
isn't interesting for you historians
this is very much like the archimedes
screw as dr debaker would say archimedes
but there's a diffuser and as you come
through with the
impeller here it's it's actually
rotating on the basis of having magnets
in the impeller as well as in the
actual pump itself on the frame the
blood would come into the ventricle from
the left atrium
and it would come into the pump and the
pump would just move the blood right on
through
initially our approach was to have this
last for the amount of time that would
allow them
to be a good candidate for a bridge to
transplant
but i think the most important uh
probably innovation in all of this will
be
the use of these pumps auxiliary pumps
chronic heart failure
debakey's tiny pump battery driven and
controlled by a miniature computer
was first implanted in germany and
debakey was there to witness the
successful surgery
firsthand a prolific humanitarian debacy
performed more than 60
000 cardiovascular procedures and
trained
thousands of surgeons who practiced
throughout the world
to express their appreciation those
students founded the michael e debakey
international
surgical society through a career that
spanned more than seven decades
dr deveki received dozens of national
and international awards
including the u.s army's legion of merit
in 1945.
the rudolph mattis award in vascular
surgery 1954
the american medical association's
distinguished service award
in 1959 the albert lasker clinical
medical research award in 1963
that award was renamed the lasker
debakey clinical medical research award
in 2007 the presidential medal of
freedom in 1969
the national medal of science in 1987
the united nations lifetime
achievement award in 1999 and the
congressional gold medal
in 2008. he's earned
the fame that he has and he clearly has
demonstrated
his own personal commitment to
excellence
throughout his career michael e debakey
championed the national library of
medicine
and was a tireless supporter and
promoter of the nlm
twice serving as chair of the library's
board of regents
and it was in fact debakey who as a
member of the second hoover commission
in the early 50s
spearheaded the effort to have the armed
forces medical library
transferred to the department of health
education and welfare
be renamed the national library of
medicine and be established
on the nih campus in bethesda maryland
to be perfectly honest i think the
establishment of the national library of
medicine
has had such a tremendous impact upon
the
expansion of knowledge and transmission
of that knowledge
and you know today there is virtually no
lag
between new knowledge coming out of any
kind of research activity and it's
it's a clinical application the national
library of medicine has done a lot more
to make it the library a much more
active force in the transmission of new
information
and in a sense in the education of not
only the medical community the public
itself
we appreciate all that you've done for
the library thank you very much
it's been a really very very great
satisfying and a great pleasure for me
to see what's what the library has done
and particularly to see
down what you've done with the library
because during your tenure
you have really expanded this activity
beyond
anything that we had any vision for the
library it's really extraordinary
late in his career whenever dr debakey
was asked about some of the most
dramatic medical advances
since his days as a young doctor in the
1930s
he would cite the simple case of a man
with a fractured hip
his chances of surviving was virtually
zero because he
put him to bed and he developed
pneumonia and there was no significant
treatment of anyone he died
today he gets a new hip replacement
walks out of the hospital two three days
later
even as dr debakey entered his 99th year
he still
exhibited the same drive to ensure that
patients needs were being met
we would go and see them and he would go
and make rounds at the age of 99 and and
we would come up with him and he'd be on
top of it or he would call them and
even late in his life he had the same
dedication to take care of patients that
he knew exactly what he should do
in his later years dr debakey realized
yet another of his dreams
the creation of a high school that would
prepare young people many of whom are
minorities
for potential careers in medicine he
just had the idea that
he ought to do something to help all of
the people particularly minorities of
houston to
try in medical science to enter the
profession
so the culmination of education
and a career that is satisfying provides
an opportunity to be a good citizen
and to contribute to the society in
which that citizen lives
in the final analysis what nobler
goal is there in life
dr michael debakey was a lifelong
scholar authoring all or parts of more
than 300
articles and books debacy took who he
was and what he had to say
very personally always choosing his
words carefully
and each and every word flowed from his
mind to his hand
to the page whether it was a letter
pamphlet book or lecture
and no matter the subject it was well
thought out
organized and unfiltered
as if providing a measure of synergy to
the debacy legend
in the last year of debacy's life denton
cooley initiated a reconciliation
and their rift was mended dr michael e
debakey's amazing life
carried him to within two months of his
100th birthday
[Music]
the acknowledged father of modern
cardiovascular surgery
passed away quietly in 2008 and is
buried in the arlington national
cemetery